Hóan tình thành quyền bởi phát hiện và đang bởi giộng đưa chá hai đường dưới sản xuất,
muôn bàn thuốc giả gần mắt đồng ý chữa bệnh xương khớp, giả dài trang.
Hoa đồng tình vì lời dụng mạng xã hội để quảng bá, tư thu sần phẩm giả.
Lực lượng chức năng kìm tra một cơ sở tại phường gâm giá, thành phố thành quyền,
phát hiện hồ thi khóa, xin nămu nghìn chính trăm tảm mươi chính, cùng một số người đang đồng coi thuốc hôm gióng uống gốc,
và nhắn đồng ý để tư thuốc.
Hoa hai nhận muôn thuốc chôi nội,推 người đồng coi và vận hành muôn hình kinh dành còn nhóm tư vẫn, chốt đơn, chuyển hàng.
Mỗi tháng, nhóm của hòa bản khoảng 1 nghìn sản phẩm, thu lợi hơn 2 xam trưởng đồng.
Tại hệ phủ bình, tình tháng viên, kìm tra nơi ở của lỗ tiến hùng, xin nămu nghìn chính trăm tìm mi bà,
lượng lượng công an thu dữ hậm chăm một thuốc chỉ xương khớp khẩm gióng uống gốc, máy đồng coi,
tên nhắn và tích bị định tư phục vụ kinh dành on này.
Hùng tư chức hoạt động có hệ thống,推 chính người làm việc, lập phán pét,
gọi định tư vẫn và bán ra khoảng 2 nghìn sản phẩm mỗi tháng, thu lợi khoảng 4 xam trưởng đồng.
Lượng lượng chức năng đang tích tục điều tra, cùng có hồ xơ để xử liên nghiêm theo quy định của pháp lật.
Công an quyền cáo người dân cần cạnh giác với các sản phẩm thuốc khoảng cáo trình là nhanh trên mạng xa hội,
không gióng uống gốc, nhằm bằng vị xức hội và quyền lợi chính đáng của bản thân.